happy new year happy January and happy
monday we're starting off 2016 with
fresh news none of that 2015 crap let's
start the year off with some good news
sony listed 20 ps4 exclusive games set
to come out this year they released a
video with the rundown of all these
long-awaited triple-a projects such as
Last Guardian uncharted 4 and
lesser-known indie titles like fire
watch and what remains of Edith Finch
it's a long list but some of these are
timed or console exclusives so just so
we're clear the games that you need ps4
to play our horizon zero dawn uncharted
4 The Last Guardian granturismo sport
gravity rush to Ratchet and Clank
tomorrow children drawn to death and
dreams but it's not all roses for Sony
today as pfm is currently experiencing
issues the issues range from creating
accounts to signing into purchasing or
downloading things from the PlayStation
Store there's no estimate on when things
will be resolved but the Status page
contains a very familiar line our
engineers are working to resolve the
issue as soon as possible and we thank
you for your patience we'll be updating
our article with more info when we get
it so stay tuned Xbox one owners must
really like Ark survival evolved because
it just surpassed 1 million downloads on
the console an unfinished version of the
action-adventure survival game launched
on Microsoft's console last month
through the game preview program and
reached more than 1 million downloads in
under a week this is likely a mix of
free trials and paid downloads it was
also revealed that the xbox one version
of Arc currently sees more daily players
than the PC Edition the full finished
version of Arc will be available in June
across xbox one pc and playstation 4
until then a free trial for arc is
available now while the full game costs
35 bucks this price will go up when the
final version launches in June and
ending on some
news Xbox one exclusive scalebound has
been delayed until 2017 the xbox one
exclusive action RPG in development at
Osaka studio platinum games has been
officially delayed to 2017 in a message
to fans co-authored by several key
developers at platinum studio claimed
the extended deadline was necessary in
order to deliver on our ambitious vision
Platinum Games explains that the
additional development time will help
bring to life all the innovative
features and thrilling gameplay
experiences that they've planned
scalebound was first revealed at e3 2014
with van at a game director Hideki
Kamiya revealed as the project's lead I
think I speak for all of us when I say
we'd rather see a game delayed then
released as an utter unplayable mess so
although it's a bummer this is probably
a good thing so that's it for me today
but I'll be back again tomorrow and for
the rest of the week to ring in the new
year and all that juicy news see you
then